honnêtement ça va puisqu'on peut pas
faire grand-chose d'autre dehors donc ça
permet d'aller au travail mais c'est
vrai qu'on aimerait faire plus mais
c'est pas vraiment le couvre-feu qui
blogue c'est plus les activités autour
finalement alors oui je le respecte mais
c'est un peu facile pour moi parce que
j'ai une
une attestation pour pouvoir sortir plus
tard du travail je sors plus tard du
travail mais après c'est juste pour
rentrer en fait parce que tous les
magasins sont fermés donc la faire moi
je travaille là soir est un parti des
ventas j'ai terminé je rentre à la
maison
par moment j'ai même l'impression que
quand que je m'habitue comme comme les
autres personnes pour s'habituer
en fait je veux surtout pas à m'habituer
à cette situation et et on est bloqué on
est bloqué en fin on est bloqué je me
sens bloqué et je peux rien envisagé bas
après 18 heures jeu bon c'est compliqué
de faire quelque chose dans la jungle de
programmer quelque chose pour la journée
j'arrive à le respecter même si j'en ai
pas envie même si je comprends la
situation
voilà c'est toujours les deux versants
qui sont en duel bah le couvre-feu ne
vit pas si bien que ça et d'égarement de
l'iba j'en profite pour me balader en
dehors de paris
sorti à la ville et bien baladé par
exemple pour la marde je pensais j'ai
envie de le pouilly si voilà trouvé
d'autre échappatoire pour sortir du
cadre classique
bon c'est assez triste parce que c'est
beau métro boulot dodo on travaille on
chez soi et puis on se retrouve de soi
devant l'ordinateur soit d'avoir la télé
on voit plus grand monde c'est triste
depuis le début on ou non toujours faire
des choses
différentes et le confinement le couvre
feu mais j'ai toujours essayé de
respecter ce qu'on nous demande est bon
des fois c'est frustrant mais on essaye
de faire ce qu'on peut quoi ben disons
que j'essaye d'avoir un petit peu
d'activité parce que sinon c'est la
dépression
voilà et que bon bah je rentre un peu
plus tôt pour pouvoir faire mes courses
voilà c'est tout mais je ne sais pas et
je ne pourrai pas vous répondre si c'est
utile ou pas parce que le coc vie tu vas
pas me va pas nous sauter dessus à la
figure comme ça et je pense que c'est le
rapprochement des gens dans les grandes
surfaces et dans le métro qui peut
causer
si vous voulez le la propagation du
virus
on est là regardez la montre on est on
est pressé comme là je cherchais mon
fils faut que je me dépêche à rentrer
chez moi et c'est compliqué